l'abondant courrier que leur seul mois
pour que les micro trottoirs de gérard à
biot une réflexion revient très souvent
au fil de vos pages c'est normal que les
gens ne sachent plus rien les études ne
sont plus ce qu'elles étaient de mon
temps on apprenait les départements les
préfectures et sous-préfectures et ben
oui ça a bien changé pour se rendre
compte à quel point en cette période de
grandes migrations saisonnières
monsieur pas bio a voulu connaître sur
l'eure là somme de vos connaissances en
faisant la manche micro en main dans les
rues de montpellier pas que je vous
parle de la somme en jeu c'est pas moi
je parle de lettre 10 15 me en vous
placeriez vous le stum vous-même mobile
quand je vous parle de l'anjou voyez ce
que c'est qu'est ce que ça peut être
c'est à dire qu'un temps mais le
physique ont visé picon mais la crosse
contre l'ajout n'avait pas l'air d'être
sur comment se fait parce que je n'ai
jamais jamais jamais jamais entendu
parler de l'anjou pourquoi les gens qui
manipulent la meuse voyez ce que c'est
que la meuse
oui ça fait je me mets pas si comment un
pastis pourquoi la meuse
et c'est quoi la meuse la bière organes
d'information presque tous les jours
j'ai jamais entendu parler de lyon
la france est loin de saint-etienne
rageant mais jamais non je connais très
bien la région soutiennent et de lyon
vous avez jamais entendu jamais non j'ai
pas c'est même très souvent est ce que
vous en pensez et pour tous les goûts
je pense quand il ya des lions peut-être
que des bêtes lâchées par les ménages
vous placeriez vous l'aube
l'obv disons que moi je la passerai plus
tôt à l'est c'est à dire les eaux la
france l'a fait dire ça c'est le soleil
se lève à l'est et donc il me semble
logiquement le soleil loupes devrait
apparaître le plus tôt a laissé la
france
si je prends la france comme dans une
grande ville de l'aube une grande ville
de loos je dirais strasbourg la touraine
ça vous dit quelque chose à tours n 6 2
le jus de la belote en impôts qu'on dit
en tout cas outre un fourre-tout pika on
ne dit pas à trouver la touraine ça
n'existe pas que pensez-vous du pas de
calais non mais là je suis pas au
courant
on parlait du pas-de-calais je sais pas
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
à votre avis non mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pas de calais
à votre avis qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pas de calais qu'est ce que vous
entendez par pas de calais
qu'est ce que vous entendez vous même
par pas de calais mais moi j'ai entendu
moi j'ai pour moi qu'il faut poser la
question c'est vous oui je vous dis pas
de calais je sais on voit pas ce que
vous voulez dire à votre avis et le
sancerrois alors ça serait quoi
c'est à dire c'est comme ça tu vois
c'est à dire ben alors à couper la tête
à qui bah oui 16 et à l'inde autre il y
en a un paquet mais bon c'est devenu
après ce d'être royaume si c'est devenu
la république alors le sancerrois
jusqu'à la république ouais si je vous
dis dijon de quoi vous parlez
dijon de gens non non dijon dijon 10 jan
je vous dis dijon savons quelque chose
dijon je vous prie de m'excuser ont
rejoint le foot
dijon le jonc vous n'avez jamais entendu
parler dijon dijon ça vous dit dit jean
jean à moins que ce soit une ville à
moins que ce soit une videmment que ça
envoie à mende ce soit la vie la ville
disons 2 je dis non
la gironde ça vous dit quelque chose
agir en iron ii c'est une femme très
bien fait avec des formes avantageuses
ah c'est vous voyez je vois pas de 2,7
me voir alors la gironde qui bien
informée j'ai dit ce que mon choix je
dois préciser quand même que dans ses
interlocuteurs il y avait un recteur
d'académie c'est pour vous dire ta bio
qui piègent tellement ses interlocuteurs
il pose des questions un peu biaisé
comme frag certains seraient savoir il
est souvent très abattement
[Musique]